IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Hi, everyone.
I am Ibrahim Ulukaya from
YouTube API Developer
Relations Team.
And joining me, Roman Nurik
from Android API Developer
Relations Team.
ROMAN NURIK: Hey, guys.
How's it going?
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: And today, as
you guys already figured out,
we'll talk about the YouTube API
integration with Android.
And so it'll be like
an Android app.
We just open sourced YouTube
Direct Lite Android app.
And we'll talk about the design
principles going on
with it, as well as the YouTube
APIs we used and the
YouTube Direct Lite.
So maybe let's get it started.
What is YouTube Direct Lite?
As you guys are always asking
in Stack Overflow, you ask
about how I can actually get
videos from other people.
How can I let other people
upload videos to my account?
Actually, for the privacy
issues, we don't actually want
you to share your password or
share your YouTube account and
let everyone upload into
your YouTube channel.
So rather than that, we just
created YouTube Direct Lite.
What YouTube Direct Lite is, it
lets people upload to their
own channel but sends a
notification for your
playlists so that you can
moderate that playlist, and
you can approve which
videos you want
to be on your playlist.
So once they upload it, they
actually come to a pending and
moderation playlist, and you
approve any video you want.
And they actually come to
the real playlist you
want to show the world.
So this way, you have the
first [INAUDIBLE]
moderation before
they go public.
And for this one, we also want
to create, a mobile app.
This way, we actually started
with the YouTube Direct Lite
Android project.
And so separate from the
project, we actually want to
gather the best YouTube API use
cases, as well as the best
YouTube Android design cases, so
that you guys can use as a
reference project.
All of this project is open
sourced on GitHub,
github/youtube/ytd-android.
And you guys, feel free to
contribute back, as well as
customize it and use it
for your own use case.
Like use cases could be, you
could request your fans to
upload videos for your website
or your service.
And then you can create a
YouTube competition and let
people upload the best videos.
And you can just moderate it
and show it on your site.
So let's get started, maybe.
I'll just show a little demo, if
we can show up the screen.
So in the first menu, we
actually have the YouTube
authentication.
It actually requests both from
YouTube, to manage my YouTube
account, as well as my
Google+ account.
We will actually talk about
which APIs are we using and
why we are using them.
And starting with that, the
actual proof for authorization
is the OAuth 2.0 flow.
And once I make sure we're
authorized, it will start
showing all my videos,
previous videos and
[INAUDIBLE], like some
funny videos inside.
And so I have three basic
options here.
One option is, I can easily
send any of my
YouTube videos here.
I can select any of them.
I can let them play.
And once they're actually
played--
and I want to really
show that video.
Bear with me.
There's slow internet here--
I can actually send
them to YouTube.
So yeah.
The video already
started playing.
And then I actually send
it that playlist.
I can submit.
And the video's already
submitted to that playlist I
want to submit.
I actually, in this one, I
created a constant file.
So you can actually, quick,
put your [INAUDIBLE]
file list.
You can burn in the playlist
ID you want to send.
And all the submissions
go to that playlist.
The second one, you can actually
use any of the
pre-recorded videos.
We have some videos.
ROMAN NURIK: A lot
of my own videos.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Oh, OK.
Great.
And use that uploads.
And actually, there's already an
upload started, and we can
actually track the process.
If there was a longer
video, it would show
the progress better.
Or as a third option, you can
even start recording a video
from scratch.
We can have a nice
video and maybe--
yeah.
ROMAN NURIK: Wah!
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Yeah, that
shows something like us.
And maybe the cameras were
nothing else, so I've used
Android's camera as well.
And I'll just [INAUDIBLE]
and let it [INAUDIBLE] elements,
so you can see the
progress bar working for real.
We'll record a little
bit longer video.
For [INAUDIBLE] to
explain, we use--
there are three use cases.
First one, you can submit one
of your already uploaded
YouTube videos to
the submission.
You can record a new video, as
well as you can send any of
your recorded videos from
your Android device.
And they will all be
sent to YouTube.
So by using that, we use either
YouTube uploading, or
we just put an extra tag for it
so that YouTube Direct Lite
knows which playlist it will
actually send the video.
I think that's enough,
almost one minute.
Yeah.
Let's try to send this video.
And we can always
show the video.
And you already started.
So as you see, we have a
notification bar here.
It is just saying that the
initiation is completed.
It will show us the progress.
And one it's done, we will
actually be able to see.
And as another reminder, while
the video is already
processed, we will have a nice
notification saying that our
video is ready.
You can just go and
watch your video.
Now I'm on my own video
manager on my account.
And I see actually my rejected
YTDL submissions, as well as
my real playlist that I want
to send my videos on.
It has three videos, so my
videos that I shared before.
And I will actually go to
my moderation tool.
My moderation is hosted on
AppSpot, ytdirectlite.app
spot.com/static-min/admin.html.
From there, I will actually--
I already logged in with
my own account.
And I see my playlist.
And when I actually go, I
actually see those three
videos that were already
approved, as well as the
pending video that
I just submitted.
So all I need to do is actually
approve a video.
And once they approve it, if we
actually go to "Success!"
And I will be able to see the
video already in my playlist.
And if I go back to my old video
here, to my playlist, I
see that it's already uploaded
on my playlist here.
It was like the YouTube
Direct Lite app.
And by saying that, I will hand
off to Roman Nurik here
to talk about the design
principles we used, because
this app was like
real [INAUDIBLE]
at first.
I take it to Roman, and
Roman helped me a lot.
And let's see what he says.
ROMAN NURIK: OK, so let's talk
a little bit about the design
of this app.
So there's a couple of things
I wanted to talk about here.
The first is that the most
important part of this app is
that there's a single primary
general flow.
You have some sort of video
content, or you want to record
that video content.
And then you want to take it
into kind of a staging or
preview area.
And then from there, you want
to upload that video that
you've chosen or taken.
And then from there,
it basically just--
all the additional interaction
goes through the status bar
notification.
So there's a couple ways
you could do this.
The first thing to note is
actually that there's three
different ways to
ingest video.
You can choose from an existing
YouTube video that's
in your account.
You can pick an item from your
gallery, basically a video
that you've previously recorded,
kind of just on the
phone, without uploading
anywhere.
Or you can record on the fly.
So in the original version of
this app, I remember that you
had two or three big buttons.
And those buttons were Pick
a Video or Choose
From Gallery or Record.
So the issue with just
immediately throwing the user
into a place where they just
have three big buttons is that
they then immediately have to
make the decision, and it's
very static.
It's also very hard, from a
design standpoint, to make
that look really good without
compromising basic visual
design principles, like
use of white space
and things like that.
So one of the things that we
decided to do was, let's take
the most common or potentially
most common form of input, one
of the most common form of
ingestion techniques, and make
that immediately available
right as soon as
you open the app.
So as soon as you open the
app, you see your list of
existing uploads on YouTube.
And that's basically your
number one kind
of ingestion option.
If you don't really want to
choose something that you've
already uploaded, you basically
have the additional
options, which are the maybe 20%
use case, or maybe 15% use
case, or something like that.
You have those as additional
options along the bottom.
Or, if you were to do this in
your own app, you could put
this as an action at the top
right of the screen, in the
action bar.
And then the nice thing about
this is that no matter which
ingestion technique you choose,
you basically get
thrown into the same
preview flow.
You get that same big preview
view, and then with that
button, Upload to YouTube
Direct Lite.
And from there, the same
thing happens.
So it's very immediately
obvious to the user
what's going on.
So a couple of interesting
things we did here, in
addition to, obviously,
changing
around the overall flow.
First, we spent a lot of
time with the visuals.
Obviously, we're using
interesting things like
topography.
We're using Roboto Light here.
We're using Roboto Condensed
in a couple of areas.
Bold All Caps, I believe, as
the captions for
these buttons.
And that follows some of the
standard Holo design aesthetic
that you would see in
other system apps.
We are also employing some
responsive design techniques.
So it actually lives a little
better on the Nexus 7.
But the difference between here,
this screen, and Nexus
7, and say, Nexus 4, is that
on Nexus 7, you'd have a
two-column grid.
Or in this case, on a
Nexus 10, you have
a two-column grid.
Probably here, you could even
do more, like a four-column
grid or something.
But on a Nexus 4, it's
a single-column list.
And that helps mitigate some of
the white space issues that
you would run into.
So for example, if you had just
shown a list on a Nexus
10 in landscape, you'd notice
that things were very, very
long and incredibly strange
aspect ratios.
So using kind of a multi-column
grid on tablets
can help you kind of have a
much better responsively
designed app.
So outside of that,
we also used the
standard metrics on Android.
So there's the standard 48dp
rhythm and the 16dp margins.
So notice that the margins
almost everywhere along this
left edge are 16 dps.
The spacing throughout
is using 16 dps
or 8 dps or 4 dps.
That's kind of the standard
spacing model that we use.
And also, the iconography.
So originally, we had very big,
colorful, gradienty buttons.
And we switched to a more muted,
subdued, flatter style
for the icons.
So you'll notice here that the
Gallery icon is a very
standard gallery icon.
It's very flat, using
the standard--
I think it's the Holo Light
action bar style.
And then for the Record, which
record is very often
associated with the color red,
we decided to give it a
slightly different treatment.
The interesting thing about
the design aspects here is
that, actually, for these icons,
we didn't have to go
into Photoshop or anything.
We just used the Android Asset
Studio, and we went into the
generic icons generator.
We plugged in which icons from
a set of clip art that we
wanted, gave it the color that
we needed, and just exported
them to all the different
densities.
So a lot of this, we didn't
really need any sort of
special Photoshop work for.
We just kind of did the design
in the XML editor--
in the Layout Editor
in Android Studio.
Actually, it was in
Eclipse, right?
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Yeah, it
was in Eclipse, yeah.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
So we did the design in the
Eclipse ADT plug-in, and then
all the icons are from the
Android Asset Studio.
So overall, the design is
very straightforward.
We use a lot of the solid
techniques that we have
readily available.
So overall, it's a solid design
for a sample app.
It's really good.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: And actually,
plus the design, you also use
a few Android techniques.
Like here, you're actually
able to use the
NotificationCompat.
And from that, you're able
to show our progress.
As well as when the video is
ready, you are able to show
them, it's ready to
watch your video.
You click, and you will be
able to see your video.
On top, we also--
maybe we can talk
about compat.
ROMAN NURIK: Actually, really
quickly, we wanted to talk
about NotificationCompat.
So I forgot which API levels the
YouTube player supports.
But notifications, there's some
notification features
that are only available in
Android 4.1 or later.
So for example, if you wanted to
have additional actions or
a big image in your
notification, you wouldn't be
able to use some of
those new APIs.
So we have this class called
NotificationCompat.
It's in the support library.
It basically lets you use some
of those newer APIs on any
version of Android.
So here, for the notifications,
I believe you
used the NotificationCompat
class for that.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: And by also
using NotificationCompat, a
separate thing.
When I want to actually start
the upload, I didn't want to
upload to interfere
with the app.
So if the user is anywhere,
using the app, and starts the
upload, and if the user goes out
of the app or just closes
the app, I really want the
upload to still continue.
So I create as an
IntentService.
So actually, the IntentService
are like the ones that are
actually using the
Compat here.
And by using that, it feels much
more lightweight than if
it was a separate thread,
basically,
going the whole process.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah,
IntentServices are great for
something like this.
IntentServices are basically--
so a service is just something
that runs in the background.
It doesn't have a
UI, obviously.
But the service, it actually
runs on the same
thread as your UI.
So if you do nothing with
threading and just simply use
a service, it will actually be
doing its work on the same
thread as your UI, so
it can hang your UI.
An IntentService is actually
a very, very nice thing.
What it basically does is it
spawns a thread to do its job.
And after its job is done,
basically after the
onHandleIntent method is
completed, it stops the
service, it stops itself,
and it kills the thread.
So it's a very nice way.
And actually, also, it does
queuing built in.
So if you call an IntentService
three times, and
it's in the middle of doing its
first task, it'll actually
queue up the other two,
and it'll then
finish the other two.
After it's done with those,
it'll then kill itself.
So it's a really, really great,
handy class for doing
any sort of downloading or
uploading, things like that.
Very, very good class to use.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: OK.
Thanks, Roman, for going
over the design.
Now actually, I also want to
talk about a little of the
YouTube APIs we used and
how we utilized them.
So we basically started
with the
authentication, as you guys saw.
It was OAuth 2.0.
For that, we used the Google
OAuth credential.
It's really handy [INAUDIBLE] so
that you don't need to deal
with tokens.
You don't need to
refresh them.
Or if there's an exception,
the exceptions are all
covered, and you're able to
handle them much easier than
if it was a [INAUDIBLE]
exception.
So the OAuth 2.0 for the Google
OAuth credential was
easy to go through,
the OAuth 2.0.
As well as if there's an
exception, like Play service
is not available, it'll be
able to understand that.
Or if there's something, like
a recordable exception, like
maybe you just lose your
authorization, it will
actually pop up an [INAUDIBLE],
if it will be
under its own authorization
screen that will show up, and
you will be just able to go
through it without any error.
It's way cleaner.
It actually helped clean half
of my code, basically.
It was just authentication, but
it was a really big deal.
And I definitely suggest to
use Google OAuth account
credential for that.
And on top of that, we used
resumable uploads.
Resumable uploads are actually
in the Data API, which lets
you do the uploads
piece by piece.
If the upload fails, [INAUDIBLE]
try, so that your
upload can start where it was
left off, in the closest place
where it was left off, rather
than going all the way back
and starting from scratch.
If you are uploading a
big file, it's super.
And even if you upload a smaller
file, it's actually a
really good approach
to do the uploads.
And I actually used the normal
Java resumable uploads with
the Java library for it, and
just plugged it into Android,
and everything worked perfect.
In the uploads, we actually
use a pull processing.
What we do is actually using
Data API, once we've started
uploading, with an exponential
backoff we've introduced, we
just keep--
pull the processing status.
And once the video is ready,
then we just show that you can
now watch our video.
We just throw another progress
notification using
NotificationCompat.
We definitely use a lot of the
Data API here, just to
actually grab your own videos
from your uploads playlist.
And then your actual uploading
is the Data API as well.
And the actual YouTube Direct
Lite submission is basically
just adding a [INAUDIBLE] tag,
adding the playlist YouTube
Direct Lite dash playlist
ID, kind of tag.
So once we upload, [INAUDIBLE]
will understand which playlist
you want to submit
those videos.
And it was like a Data API.
We use a little bit on the
Google+ API so that, from the
Google+, we really want
to see who you are.
And we really want to show
actually who you are, and we
really want to show that we
understand you, actually.
We know who you are, and we
want to make sure that,
actually, you are the right
user to send that.
You're not using someone's
account.
In that, we actually grab your
profile picture from Google+
as your identity.
And if you just go back to
the demo a little bit.
And on the demo, which you can
see, actually, there, like
Google+ share buttons, the
Google +1 buttons.
And so [INAUDIBLE]
I actually went here.
And in the meantime, I actually
am reminded of one
thing that I should have
just said before.
So when you actually click the
Google+, you can actually
publicly share the button.
Or you can just undo it.
And an Android [INAUDIBLE]
I just forgot to tell before, we
also use the Up navigation.
So if you're on any of the
pages, and you are like
reviewing, you want
to go back.
Rather than always using the
normal Back button, you
actually have a really
nice Up navigation.
So it will take you to
the home screen.
You create like a navigation
tree for that, and so your
actual activity knows
which app to back
over once your activity--
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
And actually, it used
to be very difficult
to implement Up.
Well, not really difficult, but
it used to require a lot
of effort to implement
Up correctly.
But now literally with just a
couple of additional things in
your manifest, you can basically
say that this
preview activity--
kind of the staging area,
as I call it--
this preview activity,
its parent
activity is the home activity.
So then Android knows that when
the user presses the Up
button, it basically reads that
manifest and says, hey, I
want to be taken to
the home activity.
And it will just do
all that for you.
In the past, you'd have to
actually implement the
onOptionsItemSelected call.
And that was just
too much work.
So we very much simplified
that.
And this uses it quite a lot.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Glad
that's so simple.
Took me like five minutes,
and I really enjoyed it.
And also, we used the Android
Player API to play those
videos on the Play SDK, so that
we don't need to create a
whole new UI view for that.
Just using the player, we just
customized it a little bit.
And the player's [INAUDIBLE]
how to handle all the
actions on it.
Like we can go all the
way to full screen.
And we're able to watch the
video from the [INAUDIBLE]
where it was left off.
And going back, and it
[INAUDIBLE] taken just like
something from that.
ROMAN NURIK: And this preview
or staging area, it supports
both the video view for things
like stuff that was taken from
your camera or the gallery, or
the YouTube Player API, which
is for something that
you chose from
that grid in the beginning.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Yeah, so we
really wanted to make a
complete similar interface
for both of them.
So you actually understand that
this is a second step.
You are not lost in which
step you are.
You really known there is a main
step that you can use,
choose either record,
pick any of your
existing videos, or play.
And then second step,
you just approve it.
And it comes to the main stage,
and it will just tell
you that you're either
uploading, or
it's already submitted.
And I guess that was all about
the YouTube Direct Lite for
Android app.
And thanks a lot for joining
me today, Roman.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah,
glad to help.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: And I think we
always want to plug that as
a developer relations team, both
YouTube and Android, we
are hiring almost everywhere
in the world.
ROMAN NURIK: Always hiring.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: We're
always hiring.
I hope you join us.
And to remind again, you
can always apply from
developer.google.com/jobs, as
well as I just want to mind
the open source project is
github.com/youtube is the
YouTube repository, slash
ytd dash android.
And thanks for joining
[INAUDIBLE].
Ibrahim Ulukaya and Roman
Nurik from New York.
ROMAN NURIK: See you guys.